herzlich kommt zu diesen absolut geilen
video mit abbas hatte ich wurde ab sogar
stellen genau und wir spielen heute in
kehl ist gleich ein gehalt sondern das
heißt wenn rehwinkel macht krieg ich
quasi weniger geld voll scheiße aber
wenn ich ein quell macht weil sich
täglich eine gehaltserhöhung weisen hast
du das hat es mir gar nicht gesagt dass
sie das spiel also also hab ich gesagt
nur durch jaja das team noch mehr mache
als du quasi ein alles mehr zuzüge sind
gut zu müssen habe ich 50 euro gesagt
ich mache eigentlich unternehmen jetzt
übertreiben wir haben übrigens auch in
anderen teil aufgenommen
aufrichtig kanal checkte ist eine
beschreibung der thomas ich glaube nicht
dass ich das nötig aber machen danke
obwohl lassen
wir haben den spot aus allen videos
glaube ich schon
zwar geht man bei mir länger dauern aber
ich kann nichts machen reden kannst es
nicht einfach kann ich alles machen ohne
dass ich meine chance eingestellt hat
muss man das ist sein
na gut ich hab auch ne ja wenn derzeit
kannst du kannst habe und ich nicht teig
ist schon eher was wir sind im minus 150
euro bereich an der stelle
ich hoffe trägt muss ich musste ganz
nach hinten hat da hat der last der
zeitnah also ist ja nur mein gehalt das
erstmal steht auf der kippe steht
[Musik]
ich habe keine shotgun gott sei dank ja
drei kills 1 thomas also also die regeln
sind ja quasi so ja dass erst die zweite
grund erzählt ich glaube nicht also ich
weiß es nicht ich glaube ich aber nicht
also weiter ich guck mal kurz den bogen
nach
man muss also weiter naja also nee nee
nee also passt nicht passt das heißt du
bist das quasi dass das schon mal jetzt
- 350 steht ja thomas also ja ja wir
schaffen das gab es eine waffe
thomas ist die lobby du bist ja wieso
denn immer dahin wo englischen ist das
ist es deine taktik das nicht sterben zu
lassen wir die kirche machen wenn gut
bin und dazu sagen und dann zu sagen
jaja thomas ich wirklich wollte ich noch
ich hol dich noch keine angst das ding
wäre hätte ich halt mich holen können
kennst du das hundehaus kennst du auf
oder eine weile wieder sich leider immer
ach so ich guck da nicht immer ach so
doppel war von der sniper mit der kampf
echt viel an
ich kann also ich würde annehmen was ich
an der stelle damit haben wir den gegner
thomas
einmal mehr da hast du ja ja ja ja nie
was nicht auch schon älter er wird
angezeigt
jaha anzeige buckley du hättest du auch
überfordert das ist praktisch wenn man
stirbt deswegen ich geh jetzt mal los
nahm ich mache pakistan messe
gehaltserhöhungen dagegen waren denkt
macht haben sich ja erst ab juni werden
es 50 euro obendrauf nee also dass auch
noch mal das wird er - genommen ich habe
jetzt aber thomas 50 euro im prinzip und
ich so wenig verstanden oder naja ich
hab mir meine kommentare was ich mir
jahr 2050 euro verkaufen soll
er ist einer der schon da und du weißt
ja da so habe ihn ein 40er ag nicht
gegeben ich habe ihn 120 schaden gemacht
kommen schnell geht alle der politik von
dem anderen
wenn du jetzt einbaus thomas nie so
richtig jetzt anbau und ich komme aber
zu dir
ja aber der erste keller steht auf jeden
fall man meint die eigentlich aber die
man muss gott maul halten ich bin aber
es ist doch klar
aber ich hatte jetzt immerhin schon ein
kind mehr als du ja und herrlich
geschenkt bekommen post bis jetzt - es
ist ihr bewusst dass ich jetzt gleich
raus in den letzten und zwar glaubt mir
da jetzt mal wirklich sagt er wenn du
jetzt ganz andere sterben wir das nicht
ganz schnell viel passieren würde mich
am acker machen trend ist geschädigt
absolut ja ich glaube genau da wo ich
mag niemand im kletterpark doch zwei
aber in dem gebäude wo ich bin ich mal
zu mir rüber kommen nochmals zwei gegner
ich komme zu dir dem 18 gegeben
war ich muss nach vorne geht gerne range
waffe weiße hast du eine pumpgun campus
nicht für den stromer sagen aber dass
ich dachte schon weil ja komm wir so
viele menschen draußen ja und der
gegentreffer genau der ist klar hast du
gesagt hast schon im keller
ich habe ihm kann ich will auch gar kein
hallo und das mal ausruhen möglichkeit
haben dass das so ist sehe ich mir vom
gehalt her ich mir selber komm mal her
zu mir ja bin ich aber 190 bekommen aber
von mir dauernd manchmal 30 hits
bekommen das hatte er auch schon wieder
weg zu denken
in dem haus trainer ja weil ichs grad da
sie tanzen
ich tanze vollidiot urs dahin gebaut als
geworfen du bist ja mein gott bist du
weg alter zu schaden ich habe mein herz
gegeben in der luft ja aber das war ja
weil du diese schreibt hans kaufmann du
bist wohl schlechter mitspieler also
dass die tanzgarde auf mich geworfen und
jetzt wissen die treppen warte und
machen nicht gewartet war es ein problem
ja ich wollte den pflanzen lassen
er war das war ich warum schreibe vor
dass wir jetzt ein bin
thomas also schon mal das kann ich mir
also ganz weit draußen gar nicht weit
draußen ausstellung thomas irgendwie
also wirklich so ich fühle mich noch
nicht reicher aber ich habe schon
immerhin 100 euro die ich jetzt mehr im
monat mit und 50 euro der vor seinem 50
thomas noch mal ich habe mir ganz klar
am anfang gesagt 50 für jeden fall den
ich hab ja aber was kriegt ich denn für
kids
[Musik]
das machen wir so nicht also man hat da
habe ich daraus ich hatte damals gesagt
thomas haben wir nicht so gesagt das
haben wir anders gesagt und wenn ich
jetzt mal so auf escape drückt dann
sehen wir auch dass du hier null case
hast du nicht zwei haben ganz klar
gesehen
ok alles klar wenn du das video online
stellen auch reagieren und replay zeigen
was nicht der fall ist okay erster
angriff genommen ja wenn ich das nicht
wenn ich das alles pharma-lotto das 0 1
das traffic dass wir vorne hin brachte
den dusel komme ich eine auftriebs puder
den hof streeps bruder ok stehen wir 25
lauter
maximal sind maximal 2.000 1250 euro die
hier noch machen kann also noch mal mit
den 150 euro die ja schon habt ist ein
bisschen wie hast du nicht abstehen
das waren die regeln ich habe die folge
extrem buch nacht geträumt hast du
dieses regelwerks ist mir aber selber
ausgedacht kommst du herzen oder nicht
münster wer mit einer unterdeckung
gerutscht mich denken an die firma und
20 männer 44 leute ich glaube die team
tatsächlich denkst du dem team allem der
kugel mit einem 20 jährige geben nochmal
nochmal 20 schulen die einfach nur gut
da muss ich ganz schnell los
dann kommst du da runter ohne schaden zu
nehmen so sind auch noch gegner
das sind dagegen erst jetzt auf die
drauf rippen
über den knopf gehauen die wechsel kommt
da ja ich will vielleicht ist es jetzt
nicht okay stelle ich bin tot es ist
passiert
ich bin runter gefallen lassen doch was
tun wir ja einfach die tiger vorne
runter gehen wissen geht aber mir war
das land thomas ja nein
wo ist der rest ist super
so haben 90 bundeskanzlers hochziehen
dicker pulli zone kommt dass er einen
tag danach müssen wir mal lustig und
modernisten akkumulation dicker und
aktion sollen jetzt kannst ja auch eine
betroffene mutter verstehen
[Musik]
thomas hallo auf zeit geht es da oder
von ihr kommt erstmals eine junge sich
ja ich hab ich habe 140 okay
die land nicht die fliegende monster
klaus habermann ist die gefahr dass wir
die hab ich gesehen eingeloggt war da
oben das ist halt auch noch 105 gegeben
alles okay mit super long kann man
müsste es eigentlich müssen eigentlich
dahin sind die guten sagt er
meine lage für den stil ich habe den so
viel schaden gemacht die auch mal war
meiner ich habe dirk ist hier liege der
thw ganzen winters ist dein erster was
ist dein ernst ich habe schon einen
tatsächlich bei uns muss man hier auch
mal thomas
die lange kette
ich gebe mir sowas von artikeln
jetzt kommt er so walter
hiller der hat wirklich nichts
geschissen gekriegt da plötzlich da der
wechsel hat sich ins hohe alter
wir haben eine situation der bruder
bekommt was hierdurch sind die sind
unter uns vor unter uns hinter uns
bekommen
doch nicht sein dass meine gewinnen aber
als ob wir ihn geholt haben ja jetzt
hast du acht war es ist jetzt die harte
arbeit nicht erwischen
ich dachte ja dass vier oder fünf gut
was ist eine gehaltserhöhung
ja also ich meine ich habe ja jetzt auch
viele kills gemacht deshalb habe ich
hatte einen ring geholt und war jetzt
mehr ich angebot gemacht
[Musik]